look around the room you're sitting in
right now let's fill it top to bottom
with trillions of grains of sand
billions of grains of rice hundreds of
thousands of grapes a few thousand
apples and a dozen watermelons this is
what the inside of your cells looks like
in terms of numbers they're mostly
filled up with water molecules the
grains of sand
water gives the cells insides the
consistency of soft jelly and enables
other things to move around easily
almost all the other things the rice and
fruit are proteins several billion in
total more than ten thousand different
kinds depending on the function of the
cell
your cells are basically protein robots
as is all life really
in fact all solid non-fat parts of your
body are mostly made out of protein even
your bones
proteins are dead things that make life
happen
how does this work the language of life
cells need to do many very hard things
to stay alive get food in and waste out
grow and build structures Escape danger
or react to stimuli make copies of
themselves and so on all of this is done
by speaking the language of life and the
words of this language are proteins this
is how this language Works in a nutshell
it all begins with amino acids tiny
organic molecules
they're the alphabet of the language of
life there are 21 different ones like
different letters
amino acid a amino acid b c and so on
if you put around 50 amino acids
together they form a protein which in
the language of life is a word and if
you put many of these protein words
together you get a sentence called a
biological pathway let's oversimplify a
bit and say for example your cell needs
to break down sugar with the language of
life it may take the amino acids for the
letters b r e a and K to form the
protein word break
then combine this word with other
protein words to form a biological
pathway sentence that means break down
sugar
in reality this language of life is so
complex that it defies imagination you
need to know about 8 000 words to speak
a human language really well but in the
language of life there are an estimated
twenty thousand and while the average
English word has five letters human
proteins have an average of 375 amino
acids the longest protein has more than
thirty thousand
and cells need to execute thousands of
steps at any moment if they ever stop
speaking the language of Life they die
okay but how do Mindless cells speak a
language this complex
let's dive a little deeper there are 21
amino acids that can be combined to form
proteins
and proteins are made up of dozens to
hundreds to thousands of amino acids for
the average protein length of a human
cell of 375 amino acids you get a
stunning 6.8 times 10 to the power of
495 possible proteins your cells can
make a quadrillion Google Google Google
times more than there are atoms in the
universe
most of these possible proteins are
useless just like with human language
most random letter combinations are just
gibberish so you need to know which
words which proteins make up a language
to speak it properly
and this is the job of your DNA a long
sequence of instructions
if you untangle the cell's DNA it would
be about two meters long all of your
body's DNA combined into one long string
would reach to the Sun and back over 20
times
around one percent of your DNA is made
up of genes which are basically protein
dictionaries that contain all the words
of the language of Life your cells speak
but genes are also the building manuals
for all the proteins your cells need to
function the rest of your DNA is
probably not useless but basically like
a set of rules it's like the book of
grammar of the language of Life which
proteins need to be built at which time
how many of them do you need which
protein words go together and why
okay letters words sentences dictionary
and grammar but of course this is all
just a metaphor for something
mind-numbingly complex let's dive a
little deeper to catch a glimpse of
reality
how dead proteins make life
now that we have some basic principles
we have a chance to understand how dead
things make life together and for that
we need a fundamental force of the
universe electromagnetism
the elementary particles that make up
atoms which make up amino acids have
different charges that attract or repair
each other the 21 different amino acids
all have slightly different charges
some are more negative others more
positive
when your cells build proteins they put
different amino acids together in Chains
basically long strings now because of
the different charges of the amino acids
used these strings begin to fold in on
themselves this folding process is so
complex that we still haven't completely
understood how exactly it works but in a
nutshell 1D strings become 3D structures
proteins are basically 3D puzzle pieces
with a very specific shape in the world
of proteins shape is everything because
its 3D shape determines which areas of a
protein are charged in which way and
this determines how it can interact with
other proteins
all of these differently charged puzzle
pieces can snap together or repeat each
other
when they snap together their charge
changes which can make them change their
shape which then makes them a new
protein a new tool that can do new
things
this is what makes proteins so
incredibly powerful you can do basically
everything with them they can snap
together like Lego pieces to build
complex structures they can dismantle
things they can form complex micro
machines that use energy to do work and
maybe most stunningly they can convey
information let's say there's a toxic
chemical entering your cell there may be
a protein shapes to snap to that toxin
if the protein finds that toxin it
changes its shape with that new shape it
can now snap into a different protein
that changes its shape again this new
protein activates a micro machine that
directly binds to your DNA to order the
production of a special protein which
acts as an antidote to the toxin
this Cascade of interaction is the
pathway we spoke about earlier a
sentence in the language of life
so without a single active thought
proteins have fixed a problem and saved
the cell's life in reality these
Pathways can have dozens to hundreds of
steps
our life operates is so incredibly
orange using
somehow mind-numbingly complex
interactions between dumb and dead
proteins create a less dumb and less
dead sound
somewhere around here life happens but
we still don't know what life is
how dumb things are smart together
we need another analogy so let's talk
about ants ants share a fundamental
property with cells they are really dumb
a single ant will just stumble around
uselessly but if you put a lot of ants
together they exchange information and
do amazing things constructing complex
structures organizing themselves caring
for Broods or attacking enemies
although dumb individually together they
become something greater this phenomenon
occurs all over nature and is called
emergence it's the observation that
entities have properties and abilities
that their parts do not have
this is how everything in your body
works your cells are bags of proteins
Guided by chemistry but together these
proteins form a living being that can do
a lot of really sophisticated things
cells are Mindless robots that are even
dumber than ants but many of them acting
together form specialized tissue and
organ systems from muscles that make
your heartbeat to brain cells that make
you think
if you look outside at the incredible
Dimension and scale of space a place
where forever is a real thing it's
almost impossible not to feel a bit
small not special but if you look inside
into what you really are you just
discover almost Indescribable complexity
the beautiful language of life
almost everything in the universe
reveals hidden layers of complexity if
you look closer and if you have the
knowledge to understand it to help you
with that we've created a series of
lessons to take your scientific
knowledge to the next level made in
collaboration with our friends at
brilliant.org these lessons give you a
deeper understanding of the topics from
our most popular videos from rabies and
mammalian metabolism to climate science
and black holes
brilliant is an Interactive Learning
tool that makes maths science and
computer science accessible with a
Hands-On approach because we know that
to really learn something you've got to
do it
think of each lesson as a one-on-one
tutoring version of a kotz gazard video
brilliant has thousands of other lessons
to explore as well from math space
topics like algebra and probability to
the concepts behind algorithms and
artificial intelligence if you liked the
biology discussed in this video
Brilliance course on computational
biology teaches you many important key
Concepts you'll learn about DNA
instructions RNA and protein folding
then learn how those concepts are used
to tackle modern challenges like genome
sequencing and human health to get
Hands-On with cutzark lessons and
explore everything Brilliance has to
offer you can start your free 30-day
trial by signing up at brilliant.org
nutshell there's even an extra perk for
Cutz art viewers the first 200 people to
use the link get 20 off an annual
membership once their trial ends we love
seeing how the gears interlock with our
search brilliant gives you the tools to
understand how everything fits together
the story of the human cell continues
with our human cell poster a visually
stunning Deep dive into the intricate
workings of the smallest unit of life
like all the sciency things in our shop
it's designed with love and produce with
Care by us here at kotskazakt
thank you
[Music]